depuis trois mois gérard travaille au
jardin de cocagne à magny les hameaux
une association d'insertion loi 1901 qui
cultive des légumes bio distribue chaque
semaine à des adhérents consommateurs
sous forme de paniers comme la plupart
de ses collègues gérard à intégrer les
jardins suite à une période de chômage
une manière de ne pas rester inactif
d'ailleurs retrouver vous retrouver des
personnes déjà équipés je peux parler
discuter puis bien rigolé comme mes
collègues au fond derrière et puis c'est
super league et quoi c'est europan au
goût au travail pour certains les
jardins c'est également l'occasion
d'envisager une reconversion
guy a travaillé pendant 12 ans dans les
pompes funèbres du jour au lendemain il
s'est retrouvé sans travail orientés par
pôle emploi il a frappé à la porte des
jardins de cocagne en mars 2011 et
découvert le métier qu'ils
souhaiteraient exercer marée chez moi
ici mon quotidien c'est travailler tous
les jours ici c'est super je change de
travail je vais des mottes des modes de
terre que
de terreau que je sème déjà dans la
serre ici puis que je récolte en 2012
plusieurs personnes ont déjà récolté les
fruits de leur travail quatre ont trouvé
un emploi et de une formation
qualifiante grâce au suivi de
l'association gérard a obtenu un
entretien s'il est positif il intégrera
une enseigne de grande distribution dans
un mois quant à guy il entame son
deuxième cdd de 6 mois au jardin plus
motivé que jamais pour faire de sa
nouvelle passion un métier